Bonjour Monsieur pretty dog both
president madam thank you for taking the
time the basic idea mr. president was
that we speak to you because you're
going to be awarded the Charlemagne you
price on Thursday but we cannot limit
ourselves to speaking about Europe alone
because we have a very important topic
that's right you tried to save the
Iranian nuclear deal when you were in
Washington why did you fail I think the
most important thing is to maintain
stability and peace in the Middle East
in Washington and I have said this by
the way I had understood that President
Trump wanted to leave the agreement from
2015 and during our joint press
conference I had suggested that we work
on a broader framework and I am very
sorry about his decision I think it is a
mistake and this is why we Europeans
have decided like we reiterated
yesterday to remain within the agreement
from 2015 as I reminded President
rouhani we negotiated and signed this
agreement and it allows us to control
the nuclear defense activity in Iran
until 2025 but this agreement needs to
be completed on nuclear activities under
2025 ballistic activities in the region
and regional activities of Iran in Iraq
Yemen and Syria when I was in Washington
I said to President Trump don't tear
everything up but if some things worry
you let's strengthen this framework and
he decided to create tension I think
this was meant to go beyond to something
broader this is what we have to do among
European countries with the EU with
United Kingdom's Germany and France we
have to
a firm that we are attached to the
agreement from 2015 because the Iranian
regime cannot take the its activities up
again well you have heard that they are
stalling that's what they said in their
declaration of yesterday there's no
escalation and the European decision
allows us to stop activities for now and
to limit escalation and this is why we
have to work together with our partners
in order to limit an escalation of
tension in the region and this is what
we have been trying for months now and
this is also why we have to broaden
already the topics in order to bring all
the parties back to a larger security
and stability framework for the region
you are saying that the Europeans are
going to try to remain in in the
agreement and adopted but what does it
really mean without the United States
what is it worth without them is it a
proposal that's sufficient for Iran but
this is going to be our topic in the
coming weeks and months and it's the
mandate that we gave our foreign
ministers in the EU end in Iran able to
propose well it's the agreement that we
signed is everything over no because one
of the signatories draws out but the
others are reaffirming that they are
committed it is a pity because we had
anticipated and now we can regret his
decision but it's important that we all
remain obsessed by stability and peace
in the region
the situation is very different and our
transatlantic relations damaged there
are some elements of tension but there
are also elements of very strong anchor
anchoring between us and Iran and I
think we can go beyond this
through a larger negotiation that I
proposed already unless September during
the UN assembly with Angela Merkel and
Theresa May we want to work in this
direction and we have also plans on the
commercial level and I think this has to
be respected we are a very strong trade
power are the United States are an ally
partner but we have rules to abide with
the WTO rules and we have to respect
them and have others respect them as
well it is very important that we
Europeans maintain the multilateral
framework we have true convergence in
our views and we work together and fight
against terrorism together with the
United States in Syria we are working
together in the international coalition
in Africa we work together in this aisle
and Sahara zone against Islamist
terrorism so you see we have some
disagreements but nevertheless and most
importantly we have a common interest
the will to work for our common security
in the same direction we are now at a
historical point and we have to and
maintain this multilateral order which
we created at the end of the Second
World War and that is sometimes in
jeopardy we have to create the strong
moderate literalism as I said in
Washington France Germany and Great
Britain negotiated together with Iran
now in Europe you have reform ideas that
we don't endorse are you disappointed
with Angela Merkel not at all I am
waiting for her reply this is not our
only topic that we talk about Germany
waited for a long time for France to
complete its reforms and I am NOT here
to give good grades bad grades or to say
I'm discipline we work together we are
partners France had a lot of work to
accomplish and
I think today of our German friends I'm
talking to your viewers the German
citizens because I am here in Germany
and often and I think German citizens
are aware that France has been
transforming in the last year many of
you had been waiting for that we have
reformed our labor laws we had a lot to
catch up and we have created a stronger
wage agreements in a system that is
closer to the German system we reformed
our tax law than taxes for companies in
order to be more competitive to have
better results we are deeply reforming
activity sectors that were deemed
unreformed bomb I mean to say I'm
waiting for a reply but I already want
everybody to be totally aware that the
France of today is not the same as a
year ago and I am following Germany very
attentively and I think you are not
entirely aware of how much we have
changed we are now able to make
proposals and I made proposals for your
last September and we have also had some
negotiations following the elections now
until June a Germany will have to
formulate a reply and I'm waiting for
that and have a lot of hope I think that
the Chancellor and her government is
going to join us in this historic moment
and work together for a stronger Europe
and more United and more sovereign and
more democratic Europe that's our
challenge for those who follow the
events I think you see that the German
government is not working as quickly as
you had expected because we have a
different method and we also have
different views view speaking about EU
finance minister but Germany is
endorsing that everything that you
envision is not going to be a person
possible are you aware of that
well I never said that everything that I
proposed has to you have to take it or
leave it all I have an ambition I make
proposals but I am convinced that it was
my duty to do so the current status quo
in Europe is bad for everybody our
sovereignty is being tested for
everything that's happening the Iranian
crisis trade crisis challenges of the
digital world of internet energy
transition migration on our capacity to
protect ourselves we have to make
progress and we have to be a more
integrated European avant-garde I would
like economic government a minister but
you call it whatever you want actually
the end is what counts more than the
names I just want a Europe that is more
democratic and less bureaucratic I want
this Europe to be more United
concerning the essential points able to
protect itself against the big risks
that's why I want political integrity in
the eurozone responsible and solidary
policy in the last years Europe was
divided at several times division
between the North and the South because
of the financial crisis and economic
crisis and then a division between the
East and the West because of the
migration crisis do you think we can go
on like that forever no we have to
create more solidarity in front of all
those dangers and that's the reform that
I proposed I am waiting now for the
German replying together with the
Chancellor we have the target of
replying of getting a reply in June I am
following the German political life your
elections
new government I think it would be a
mistake to formulate a reply that lacks
an ambition the Germans always have the
impression that they pay the bill for
your that's not true
France pays just as much but you are
speaking to French citizens Germans it
is not French citizens so what are you
telling them what are you telling the
German viewers you have the opportunity
to talk to them directly today well I am
saying this is completely wrong since
the financial crisis it has been wrong
everybody has contributed according to
its quota Germany and France as much as
Germany we have not helped our bank
system or financial system more than
other countries we have including also
helped other countries that's why I say
we have to go further to create a new
budget that allows a real convergence of
economic policy and inside the eurozone
we need a more integrated economic
policy to have a budget that allows us
to invest we are a net contributors just
like Germany but I don't want this
policy in order for France to benefit
from it no I want to help also the other
countries that want to follow us and go
in the same direction and France has
been carrying out reforms in the last
year so I want more Europe but not for
the benefit of France
I want more Europe for the benefit of
everybody because in the situation where
we have been in the last ten years has
been beneficial for Germany because
Germany was smart enough to carry out
the reforms before the crisis and they
also benefit because there are some
imbalances outside of the Europe zone
Germany has a trade balance surplus with
most countries this cannot last that's
cannot go on like that and if we don't
go beyond our present and our future
then the euro zone is going to be
dismantled and the Europe also situation
where we are now collectively cannot
so the French proposal is not a proposal
for France it's a proposal for Europe I
am going to continue carrying out
reforms in my country and I can tell you
that to France it's a net contributor
just as Germany and if we don't reform
you Europe now we are not going to be
maintained in the eurozone and Europe we
have to go beyond our selfishness and
our taboos and our fears we have some
taboos and I am telling this frankly to
your viewers what I want is not for me
it's not for France it's for the whole
of Europe we have to go beyond our
taboos Germany has the table of
financial transfers but a eurozone
without financial transfers cannot last
France has a taboo of changing a treaty
but we will have to treat it otherwise
we can't go on question for you Germany
you have often been called Jupiter or
Caesar one year into the presidency are
you still a superhero I have never
presented myself as such so I leave the
responsibility for this comparison to
you they are not always true I think
from the first day I have been working
hard I was elected president of the
French Republic by the French people who
made a choice between extreme right-wing
candidate and what I had to propose and
many thought that it would be impossible
to be elected on the strength of a
European program I know that my project
is a very hard to carry out and I have
been working without respite from day
one we have made a lot of progress but
we still have a lot to do so I am
working hard like in the beginning but I
know I have to push France to sports
more transformation
we also have to work on the European
project because France has not
transformed fast enough in the last
year's in the last decades not with
enough vision and ambition we have
managed to master crisis sometimes just
by applying a band-aid but we have not
been as bold as our founding fathers you
cannot manage for instance to amend the
treaty if Germany does not have solution
and this is to conclude if we don't find
a solution
does the EU still have a future I'm a
fighter and I never dwell on bad things
I'm going to put all my energy into
convincing and convincing some more
about the film with Hawaii more I think
the best way to convince is to do the
job at home that's what I said from the
beginning and this is why I waited until
September to give my proposals for
reform and then you have to explain to
be humble to be constantly I have no
lessons to give I just say what I am
suggestion and then I have to go on
working and what some more and until
things are a reality I am NOT going to
choose that option that scenario because
I think that would be dramatic for all
of us and bad for Germany as well
Germany had the courage and the strength
of character to carry out very deep
economic reform already 10 years ago and
benefited a lot from the eurozone but
the situation where we are now it's not
going to be able to continue like that
so even in Germany should not remain in
this situation during the migration
crisis Germany was confronted to
selfishness from all the other countries
and has made this experience for now we
need more transparency more
responsibility from the states but we
need
a more solidary Europe on economic
financial migration topics we need a
more sovereign Europe that is able to
protect itself against the risks and
that's more United and we need to take
the step and I want your viewers to
understand that it's good for them thank
you very much